Transcriptor: TED Translators admin
Revisor: Pedro Ramirez
Yo hice en la Universidad de Valencia la Lic. de Ciencias Físicas en el 85
y quería especializarme en Astrofísica.
Si uno quiere hacer Astrofísica en España, debe ir a La Laguna.
Eso ya ocurría en el año 85 y sigue siendo así hoy en día.
Ahora mismo viene gente de toda Europa para estudiar Astrofísica aquí.
El Departamento de Astrofísica está en el Instituto Astrofísico de Canarias.
El Instituto de Astrofísica tiene dos observatorios internacionales.
El Observatorio del Roque de los Muchachos y el Observatorio del Teide en Tenerife.
Son telescopios punteros en el mundo, con intrumentación puntera,
nos visitan científicos internacionales.
El caldo de cultivo es muy bueno, razón por la cual decidí venir aquí.
Yo aterricé en Tenerife en el 85 y si entonces me hubieran dicho:
"En el 2010 daría a la sociedad canaria una charla sobre astrofísica".
En realidad, a una parte muy escogida de la sociedad canaria.
Yo creo que los que estamos aquí tenemos unas inquietudes muy concretas.
Espero transmitiros mi ilusión y aportar algo a esta sociedad.
Sería algo estupendo porque significaría que he hecho la carrera,
y que tengo trabajo de astrofísico, lo cual no era evidente entonces.
También habría pensado: "Seguro que hablo de los proyectos científicos que tengo
con observaciones hechas en Canarias." Proyectos que podéis ver aquí.
Pero me hubiera equivocado, no vengo a hablar de investigaciones
hechas en los observatorios canarios sino en un telescopio lanzado en globo
que ha volado desde el Círculo Ártico para observar el Sol.
Y lo primero que uno diría es: "Esto suena raro, ¿no?".
"Aquí hay unos telescopios estupendos, ¿por qué irse al Círculo Polar?".
Esto mismo dijo el director del IAC cuando se lo comenté.
Yo le dije: "Mira, que quiero irme al Círculo Polar a lanzar un globo".
Dijo: "¿Estás bien, te pasa algo?".
Yo le dije: "No, nada que no sepa, pero hemos decidido intentarlo".
Canarias tiene unos cielos estupendos y por eso están los telescopios aquí.
Ojalá en el futuro puedan venir más, en concreto el de 42 metros, el E-ELT,
que ha aparecido mucho en los medios.
Pero siempre hay atmósfera, eso distorsiona las imágenes astronómicas.
Uno quiere es irse fuera, al espacio. Quitar la atmósfera
y ver los objetos astronómicos con el mejor detalle posible.
Por eso unos amigos, todo ellos astrónomos y físicos, decidimos hacer el experimento.
Y esto ha sido algo raro, inesperado. Y es de eso de lo que quiero hablar aquí.
Estoy hablando de cosas... En concreto, estábamos en un congreso
unos colegas alemanes, otros americanos y nosotros, españoles del Astrofísico
y dijimos: "¿Cómo podemos ver en detalle los procesos que queremos estudiar?".
Y uno, que conocía el programa de la NASA de globos que lanzan en los Polos,
dijo: "¿Y si cogemos un telescopio, lo lanzamos desde el Círculo Ártico
y observamos el Sol fuera de la atmósfera?".
Estos globos vuelan 40 km por encima de la Tierra.
Prácticamente sin atmósfera y sin esa distorsión que os comentaba.
Y decidimos intentarlo.
Es algo que surge, como digo aquí, de abajo a arriba.
Quiero hacer énfasis en esos procesos que surgen porque la gente quiere.
No hay nadie, no hay gestores, no hay dirigentes
en la astrofísica mundial que nos digan:
"¿Por qué no lo hacéis? ¿Por qué no vais al Polo a tirar un globo?
No, es una idea un poco loca que surge.
Son cosas inesperadas y de alto impacto en este caso en la física solar,
porque los resultados han sido muy buenos, como veréis.
Nadie se imaginaba que había que lanzar un telescopio para hacer esto.
El impacto es enorme.
Según la edad avanza, cada vez me doy más cuenta
de que la vida depende precisamente de este tipo de cosas.
Cosas que no esperamos y que tienen un impacto enorme en nuestras vidas.
Igual decís: "Bueno, ese es tu caso, has tirado un telescopio desde el Ártico,
y eso es bastante inesperado". Pero nos pasa un poco a todos.
Por ejemplo, un caso concreto para que veáis que nos afecta a todos.
Google. ¿Quién nos dijo que Google se iba a crear?
¿Que Google iba a tener el impacto que tiene en nuestras vidas?
Instalas un programa, no te funciona, lo pones en Google y te da la solución.
Lo haces y funciona. Y además te crees que eres bueno con los ordenadores.
Google es bueno con los ordenadores, no tú.
Pero Google nos ha hecho eficaces.
Y nadie, ninguna agencia financianciera, ningún gobierno dijo:
"Voy a dar soluciones para esto".
Google surgió de dos estudiantes de Stanford que dijeron:
"Vamos a hacer esto". Y miren lo que tenemos ahora.
Ha hecho más eficaz a la humanidad.
Lo comparo con la Revolución Industrial. Y creo que no es muy exagerado.
Y esto son todo procesos que vienen de abajo a arriba.
Es un contexto en el que estas cosas se pueden promocionar.
Y desde luego lo del globo fue algo parecido.
En el caso de la física solar las razones eran estudiar el Sol.
Lo vemos en la playa de las Teresitas cuando tomamos el sol y nos quemamos.
Es un objeto muy interesante. Es algo más que una bola amarilla.
Aquí podéis ver el sol en el año 96 y luego en el año 1999.
Tres años de diferencia, es un Sol muy distinto.
Veis que hay un grupo de procesos o abrillantamientos locales
que aparecen y desaparecen.
El Sol es más que una bola amarilla e inerte que puede parecer aburrida.
Hay algo que está ocurriendo en el Sol y que además vemos cambiar.
En Astrofísica es muy difícil ver las cosas que cambian.
Las escalas astronómicas son muy grandes para ver que una galaxia cambia.
Pero el Sol cambia constantemente y lo podemos ver.
Esto son varios días lo que vemos aquí,
ejecutados muy rápidamente. Podéis ver que algo está cambiando en el Sol
y está produciendo todo tipo de pequeñas explosiones.
Y de hecho son, a todos los efectos, como si fueran explosiones.
Algunas de ellas pueden ser muy, muy violentas.
Por ejemplo, esto son dos horas de tiempo real pasado muy rápido.
Esto negro de aquí sale hacia arriba casi de forma balística.
Esto es una explosión magnética en la superficie, de origen magnético.
De vez en cuando hablaré de campos magnéticos,
todo lo que hace interesante al Sol son esos campos magnéticos.
Todos los abrillantamientos que veis son abrillantamientos magnéticos.
Aquí podéis ver que el Sol es esto blanco que estamos tapando,
este círculo blanco que estamos tapando.
Es el mismo proceso observado con otro instrumento.
Todo esto está observado en el espacio.
Es el único sitio donde se ven estas radiaciones ultravioleta.
Y lo que vemos es esta explosión que sale hacia arriba visto desde aquí.
Lo estamos viendo aquí, y hay algo que sale en esa dirección hacia arriba.
Es la misma explosión pero en la parte más externa del Sol.
¿El Sol tiene muchas explosiones? Pues tiene muchísimas.
En concreto, durante lo que se llama el "ciclo de actividad",
esa parte que veíamos al principio, con un Sol muy activo,
puede llegar a 4 explosiones al día. Esto es 1 mes de vida solar al máximo.
Está constantemente haciendo estas expulsiones de masa coronal.
Son explosiones de origen magnético y determinan el medio ambiente.
Para navegar por el Sistema Solar, y la Humanidad lo hará antes o después,
debes conocer la meteorología espacial, qué hace el Sol con estas explosiones.
Es un tema fundamental al que se dedica la Física Solar,
intentar predecir estas explosiones.
Lo que veis detrás, cruzando la imagen, son los planetas.
Están en órbita elíptica y por supuesto pasan por detrás.
La gran mayoría de estas explosiones parecen ir hacia abajo.
De vez en cuando veréis una explosión que rodea este círculo.
¿Qué significa cuando no va hacia abajo sino que parece ir en todas direcciones?
Pues esta explosión, lo que significa, es que viene hacia ti.
Viene hacia la Tierra.
Esta en concreto ocurrió en el 2000, en el día de La Bastilla,
los franceses dicen que el Sol estaba celebrando la Revolución Francesa.
Tenemos una explosión muy grande que incluso llega al detector
y produce estos abrillantamientos y estos chisporroteos.
Esto fue el 14 de julio, el día de la Bastilla.
Puedo repetir algo, o me podéis preguntar si algo no se ha entendido.
Estoy hablando de explosiones magnéticas en el Sol.
Aquí tenéis una explosión que ocurre muy cerca...
Muy cerca del centro del disco.
Aquí veis la explosión, este es el disco solar.
Y como está muy cerca, como se veía en los otros instrumentos
que mostraban estas expulsiones que salían haciendo 90 grados,
mientras que aquí el abrillantamiento es alrededor del Sol.
Cuando se ve eso, es que esa explosión va dirigida a la Tierra.
Y lo que ocurre es lo que podéis ver en esta animación.
El Sol tiene una explosión magnética, llega a la Tierra,
la Tierra también tiene su campo magnético y en este caso es bueno.
Es un campo magnético que nos protege, es un escudo protector.
Este campo magnético dirige toda esa reacción hacia los Polos
que son los que más sufren estas radiaciones.
Pero otros que sufren estas radiaciones
son los satélites de comunicaciones que están fuera del escudo protector.
Diréis, "bueno, peor para los satélites".
Pero es que nuestros móviles, nuestros GPS, nuestros Iphones,
todos ellos utilizan comunicaciones vía satélite
y se pueden ver afectados por estas tormentas electromagnéticas.
Un satélite de estos puede llegar literalmente a freirse
si tiene la mala suerte de que sus chips son muy sensibles a las radiaciones.
O sea que puede afectarnos, y muy directamente.
De alguna manera lo que estoy diciendo es
que el Sol es el objeto astrofísico que más nos va en ello lo que haga.
Lo que pase en una galaxia lejana puede ser interesante para una película
pero tiene un impacto pequeño en la Tierra.
Por eso el Sol es un objeto interesante que debemos estudiar
y ser capaces de predecir este tipo de explosiones.
Eso es lo que está detrás ahora mismo de la Física Solar.
El proyecto Sunrise lo que intenta,
el globo que hemos tirado desde el Círculo Polar Ártico,
es entender el magnetismo a muy pequeña escala.
Todo lo que veis aquí son imanes en el Sol.
En la Tierra tenemos un campo magnético, la brújula nos dice dónde está el Norte.
El Sol, al ser plasma, al ser gaseoso, tiene millones de brújulas
y todas ellas apuntando en diferentes direcciones.
Una brújula en el Sol apuntaría aquí y allá, estaría prácticamente loca
en función de los movimientos del plasma solar.
Este Sol es un objeto muy interesante y muy complejo de estudiar.
Saber cuál es el origen de su magnetismo y de ese tipo de explosiones
fue lo que nos llevó a proponer ese experimento Sunrise
porque para poder predecir las tormentas solares
hay que ver millones de detalles del orden de 100 km.
Hay que ser capaces de ver un rayito de Tenerife en Sol
e incluso objetos más pequeños.
Y para poder tener esa resolución la atmósfera lo había hecho imposible.
La idea fue: "Bueno, pues vamos al Círculo Polar Ártico
ponemos este telescopio de un metro en una barquilla y lo lanzamos en globo.
Este es el proyecto Sunrise. Esta foto fue tomada el día del lanzamiento.
Aquí tenéis la barquilla a la que de vez en cuando me referiré,
es la contribución americana. Esto es un programa de la NASA
que vuela globos tanto en el Polo Norte como en el Polo Sur.
En este caso el lanzamiento fue en el Polo Norte,
la barquilla es la contribución norteamericana, de EEUU.
El telescopio es un telescopio alemán.
Y el instrumento que hace la ciencia y que mide el campo magnético
es un instrumento español liderado por el Astrofísico de Canarias.
Al final, lo importante en todo son las personas.
Y estas personas le han dedicado mucho tiempo,
esto empezó en el año 2001.
Llevan muchos años trabajando estos dos Intitutos en Alemania
que han proporcionado el telescopio y el estabilizador.
La barquilla y el sistema de vuelo en EEUU.
Y el Astrofísico de Canarias con el instrumento Imax.
El instrumento IMaX, del que yo he sido el investigador principal,
aunque fue liderado por el Astrofísico es un proyecto complejo,
con una contribución de otros centros de astrofísica en España,
el INTA, Instituto Nacional de Técnica Aeroespacial de Madrid,
Astrofísico de Andalucía, la Universidad Politécnica de Madrid
y la Universidad de Valencia.
El magnetógrafo IMaX lo llevamos haciendo prácticamente desde el 2001.
Aquí lo véis en el verano del 2008, en la sala de vacío del INTA,
a punto de hacer pruebas de vacío.
Y realmente es un montón de cables y un montón cosas complejas.
Pero solo deciros que aquí dentro está el objeto más plano del mundo.
Es un elemento que es plano a más menos 1 molécula.
Es muy difícil conseguir esas planitudes.
Y necesitábamos eso para hacer espectroscopía.
Aquí teníamos tecnología muy compleja de cristal líquido
que se necesitaba para medir campos magnéticos.
Es algo que nos ha llevado mucho tiempo, realmente complejo.
Antes de este instrumento se habían hecho tres
por una empresa aerospacial de EEUU.
Es el cuarto que se ha hecho en el mundo y se ha hecho en España.
Esto es en octubre del 2008.
Cuando ya el instrumento estaba cerrado.
Todo esto está dentro de esta caja.
Este es el IMaX, la caja de electrónica del ordenador que lo controla.
Y una vez integrado y verificado se envía a Alemania.
Esto es la llegada del instrumento a Alemania en este contenedor
y va a la sala en donde los alemanes ya habían hecho el telescopio.
Aquí tenéis el telescopio que ya lo tenían los alemanes por allá.
Aquí está el sistema de plano focal que luego van a poner aquí encima
en nuestra caja de electrónica. Esta es la caja de electrónica de los alemanes.
También los paneles de las cajas de electrónica.
Y una vez todo junto nos vamos al Círculo Polar Ártico.
Nos vamos a la ciudad de Kiruna, la ciudad más al norte de Suecia,
donde la Agencia Espacial Sueca tiene la base de lanzamiento ESRANGE.
Y tenían estos sitios donde trabajar para terminar la integración.
Nosotros trabajamos todo el tiempo aquí, en el sitio de la Catedral.
Es un paisaje idílico, es muy bonito pero básicamente es un paisaje blanco.
Estuvimos desde abril hasta junio, cuando lo probamos,
en ESRANGE, en esta catedral.
Los americanos habían enviado por su lado la barquilla que tenéis aquí.
La barquilla se había hecho en pulgadas
y el telescopio se había hecho en centímetros.
Esto siempre es interesante cuando se encuentran
a ver si las medidas son las mismas. En este caso no hubo problema.
En un día, el telescopio entró perfectamente en la barquilla.
Se integró sin problemas, sin ninguna confusión que nos retrasase.
Lo primero que hicimos cuanto tuvimos algo de sol fue apuntar el telescopio
para poder calibrar el IMaX el instrumento que os he enseñado
liderado por este Centro.
Eso decía, antes de volar tenemos que mirar al Sol.
Estuvimos aquí dos meses trabajando y llegamos al lanzamiento.
El lanzamiento os lo quiero enseñar.
Si ponéis en Google "SUNRISE ESRANGE", encontraréis este vídeo.
Después de estar 9 años trabajando, este fue un momento realmente...
espectacular, como os podéis imaginar.
Voy a enseñaros solo la primera parte del lanzamiento.
Si... Windows decide reproducirlo.
Aquí lo tenéis.
El globo está agarrado por una abrazadera mecánica que se suelta
y esto de aquí es un paracaídas. Aquí hay un elemento pirotécnico
que, cuando nosotros lo digamos, explotará.
El globo sale para arriba y el telescopio lo recuperamos en tierra.
Lo veréis recuperado.
En el lanzamiento hay una grúa, que la lleva la gente de la NASA,
tienen que esperar a que se ponga en dirección...
vertical, para asegurarse de que no tiene un bamboleo muy grande.
Y sube en 2 horas a 40 km por encima de la superficie terrestre.
A 40 km has dejado atrás el 99,9% de la atmósfera
y no tienes ningún problema de distorsión de la imagen.
Esta es la grúa de lanzamiento, cuando llegue por aquí lo soltará
justo lo está amarrando aquí y el globo se irá para arriba
a la estratosfera.
El vídeo entero lo podéis ver en Google si ponéis las palabras SUNRISE ESRANGE.
El globo lo que hizo fue...
volar desde Suecia,
atravesar el Atlántico Norte, Groenlandia y lo recogimos en la isla de Canadá.
No pudimos volar sobre Rusia porque todavía no deja a los americanos,
por si les espían volando por encima. Es una herencia de la Guerra Fría.
Claro, no quieres terminar en el mar. Quieres acabar en una isla en Canadá.
Y aquí en la isla de Somerset se recuperó el espejo del telescopio,
se recuperó nuestro instrumento, que ahora está en Madrid funcionando.
Y esto es como quedó la barquilla, más estropeada, y los paneles solares.
Pero la verdad es que se recuperaron bastantes cosas.
Y desde que hemos recuperado los datos en junio del año pasado,
estamos haciendo ciencia, la ciencia ahora mismo está emocionada,
los científicos están usando esos datos y los datos son fantásticos.
Yo no voy a contar muchos más detalles,
aquí tenéis la imagen de velocidad de la superficie del sol
con más detalle nunca jamás obtenida.
Lo que veis en negro, va hacia vosotros y lo que está en blanco va hacia dentro.
Es una mapa de velocidad.
Y ese efecto de piscina,
hay un efecto de estar mirando la piscina en el fondo,
son terremotos en el Sol. Nunca se habían visto con este detalle.
Podemos ver 100 km, se verían reflejados ahí.
¿Y qué es lo que quiero decir?
Pues que esto es algo que surgió de abajo a arriba de forma natural.
Nadie nos dijo lo que teníamos que hacer.
Lo que queríamos hacer nos lo propusimos y lo hemos logrado.
Yo creo que las cosas de alto impacto y que son realmente importantes
vienen siempre de abajo a arriba.
¿Y por qué sospecho más de las cosas que van de arriba hasta abajo?
Pues porque en realidad no sabemos tantas cosas como pensamos.
Mirad, este pavo lleva mil días comiendo, todos los días a las 9 le dan de comer,
está seguro de que le van a dar de comer.
Un día a las 9, piensa que va a comer, y lo que sucede es una cosa muy distinta.
Cuando no tenemos la seguridad de qué pasará en un futuro
lo mejor que podemos hacer es que la gente actúe de abajo a arriba
porque va a ser mucho más natural
que aquellos que tenemos arriba diciéndonos qué tenemos que hacer.
Porque en realidad no sabemos muy bien qué es lo que va a pasar mañana.
Y este es el mensaje que quería enviar.
En el Astrofósico tenemos un Centro Tecnológico
pero necesitamos masa crítica y Universidades.
Necesitamos interaccionar entre todos.
Y esa interacción, creo que donde mejor se da es en foros tipo TEDx como este,
Vamos a ver qué ideas surgen. Lo mejor que podemos hacer es hablar.
E intentar proponer cosas que cambien nuestra sociedad.
Gracias.